[Applaudissements]
en sort on parle beaucoup
d'incertitudes vous croyez qu'ils
avaient des chauffailles il y avait des
choses qui étaient qu'on croyait fives
et qu'on croyait 6 pour croyait ian
levine est en fait tellement de choses
qui changent depuis deux ans c'est
incroyable le monde accélère et à lui
fasse tous à cette incertitude
je pense que la certitude ça fait partie
de la vie
et à ce titre
l'incertitude bah moi c'est mon
quotidien mais à ce titre ça fait partie
de la vie et la maladie aussi fait
partie de la vie je pense qu'on est tous
confrontés à sa charge la maladie si
pour certains des problèmes de
changement tout un tas de choses on peut
mettre tout ce qu'on veut derrière ce
terme fait
et donc à la maladie - c'est parti de
match et incertitudes aussi la
résilience pour moi c'est tous les jours
c'est tous les jours la résilience et
tous les jours c'est pas vous faites
preuve de résilience une fois à
l'extérieur non c'est tous les jours
remettre du tu passeras plancher est à
nouveau au boulot qu en fait je vis avec
la mucoviscidose
alors le muc aussi deux c'est une
maladie génétique
le médecin ensign pathologies chroniques
dégénératives
salut ça fait peur et en fait c'est une
maladie génétique donc à la ceni de
patients en france ouais je suis avec
ces mots puisque c'est jovetic est donc
il ya deux composantes à cette manette
et première par composante de la malade
qui va toucher le système respiratoire
des pompes une deuxième partie qui va
tous et le toucher toute la sphère
digestive au fait et en fait
c'est le tous les fluides du corps qui
sont dits peu plus épais alors vous vous
avez tous du mucus à l'intérieur de mon
chez moi les glucides un petit peu plus
épais ils s'accumulent et à de poussière
et de normes et des bactéries et puis
finalement de l'infection au fait et ça
s'accumule s'accumulent s'accumulent
jusqu'à ce qu'on appelle un encombrement
broschi permanent fatale et une
diminution progressive de la capacité
respiratoire
jusqu'à jusqu'à
jusqu'à la grève de boulot parce que
jusqu'à maintenant il n'y avait pas de
vrais médicaments pour faire face à
cette maladie et tambours passion c'est
encore le camp jaune je vous parle je
vous en parlerai tout à l'air mais j'ai
eu beaucoup de chansons du mois de
juillet à l'année dernière et donc 1
et donc il ya pas vraiment de
médicaments au quotidien ça c'est des
coups très exagérées ça a été depuis dix
ans de tutu et en fait j'ai 38 ans
aujourd'hui quand je suis quand j'avais
4 ans les médecins
en fait je suis les médecins à qui on
parle j'avais 80 m vous faites
aujourd'hui je n'arrive à faire mentir
les singes sont pas peu fiers et 1
est donc la deuxième volet au delà de la
balade du clan digestif en fait qui fait
que tout les sécrétions j'étais tout à
l'heure du corps souple qui s'affaisse
notamment que vous du pancréas ce qui
fait que je digère pas bien les graisses
et les vitamines les tout ce qui est bon
pour le côté anti inflammatoire du corps
et du coup bosch c'est pour ça que je
pas bien épais alors l'espérance de vie
47 ans les ménages moyens et ses 27 ans
moi je préfère dire que je vivrai juste
parce que je vivrai mais si je peux
vivre sans enfant innocent parce que si
on se détermine si on s'arrête sur le
chiffre on va pas bien loin au mieux
viser plus loin et puis hommes
et puis pour moi depuis alors je respire
depuis dix ans avec ça quand ça commence
action de 90 pirates
et même si très en forme quand j'étais
petit est aujourd'hui atteint depuis
deux ans en fait pour moi la radio
tous les jours froids en fait ça m'a mis
à l'aise plus profonde est allé chercher
au plus profond des ressources jusqu'au
plus profond de mes tripes au plus
profond de mon coeur
d'apprendre à connaître d'un
état d'esprit mon 27 sur le sujet en
fait depuis dix ans je teste des choses
tous les jours pour être mieux demain
depuis dix ans j'ai dit que je suis un
spécialiste de la maladie un médecin et
que moi aussi je peux le faire plein de
choses dès maintenant et ce en attendant
je me dis qu'à la maladie reprend que la
place que je lui laisse
la maladie pour que la place je me dis
qu'il a toujours le choix on a choisi
par le maire bottines vide est resté
dans son canapé la tendance plaindre au
lac vert s'est plaint se lever et puis
de se battre et puis d'aller chercher le
bonheur je me dis je me dis tout un tas
de petites phrases pour ça je me dis que
demain ce sera forcément meilleur
aujourd'hui parce que je poserai les
actions pour qu'il en soit ainsi donc en
fait
la maladie de m le se compare à fait
convenable je préfère l'appeler comme ça
l'un muscat les plus profondes
manuellement fait toujours à revenir au
sens de pourquoi je fais ça 2 pourquoi
je passe des journées entières sur mon
tapis de yoga parce que depuis deux ans
c'était un peu notre quotidien des
journées entières
yoga à faire en a qui n'est respiratoire
à sortir deux verres entier par jour de
mai pour deux verres 200 minutes de de
cochonneries de l'air docu par jour
c'est sale [ __ ] c'est pas très joli mais
c'est ça l'art est et à et ça revient
tous les jours tous les matins il faut
refaire ça
depuis dix ans fait ça mais depuis deux
ans je voudrais vraiment que ça j'étais
vraiment car pékin c'était vraiment très
vieux sam à venir à comprendre à avoir
deux réflexions au fait tu
as pensé à
cet état fort par moments c'était comme
si j'avais une petite flamme creux de la
main
et qu'il y avait comme s'il y avait tout
à voir quand autour de moi et que cette
petite femme il fallait quand même la
maintenir à vous allumez quoi comme il
file à protéger et dans mes actions du
quotidien l'objectif c'est de protéger
cette petite flamme de faire en sorte
qu'elle continue à briller cette petite
fois pour heures elle s'appelle l'espoir
l'espoir que
demain tu peux y ait eu peut être en
meilleure forme que je donne moi tu vas
vivre demain tu veux en faire plein de
jeunes j'ai toujours cru ans accomplis
depuis dix ans r et cette petite flamme
est tellement précieux
la deuxième histoire de vraiment compter
sur
ses seins
que je dis souvent aux autres patients
aux personnes qu'il croise divin
concerne
que tu entends vivre tu dis alors j'ai
appris au travers de mon parcours que on
parle le plus sur tout ce dont on a
besoin d'entendre au chien et un oued
ont envie je veux
dit cette phrase aussi eux-mêmes pour le
midi et en fait c'est ça la question
c'est l'envié en fait pendant le premier
vous filmant une jatte 2 ans je suis
descendue à 40% capacité respiratoire
et installe en fait un question c'est
leur vie parce qu'elles portent pas
envie tu vis c'est facile à dire mais en
fait l'enjeu c'est ça c'est la vie c'est
à voir aux heures qu'est ce que tu fais
dans mon quotidien qui dit avoir envie
de faire cette quille est passé des
journées entières tacchini sont au
taquet c'est ça vous donc de quoi tu
remplis des journées est-ce que tu
remplis de ces journées de paix smtc nul
2-2 râleries que nous juge baum djamila
1 masculin pas de masque
est ce que tu veux remplir tes journées
de sable ou d'autres choses ou
simplement de
quelque chose que j'ai connu il ya pas
longtemps en fête annuelle je me suis
tapé un fou rire de l'enfer les petits
neveux ça faisait très longtemps que ce
n'était pas pour un cessez le vivre
pleinement et en font sa vie c'est ça
c'est être capable de vivre des fous
rires et quand jean pour sa salle
d'audience à utiliser un mac ou pc mais
également par charles dunbar ap dix ans
ça fait chier quoi est un oui c'est
arrivé es trop d'impôts et puis en fait
un être capable aussi de pleurs et de
verser des larmes c'est pas de la
tristesse c'est des larmes
c'est l'émotion en fait de partager des
larmes avec les gens avec des gens comme
karine avec des gens comme ça six
puissantes armes et à
ses salles c'est partager ces deux
extrêmes
et donc en fait que c'est que ça que
j'ai envie de remplir mon avis
aujourd'hui les journées pour continuer
à avoir envie de faire une chose devient
alors comment on fait pour être
président et j'ai pas envie de parler au
nom de tous les gens qui jouent aux
victimes de toute la terre je vous
parlais pour voir comme moi je fais
parce que je parle juste voir juste paul
et en fait
quand je fais je pense que l'une des
premières choses c'est d'avoir d'avoir
ce terreau en fait de créer des
conditions de silence
parce que c'est dans le silence qu'on
écoute le menu
ski parce qu'on n'est plus à même de
former dans question de faire un thème
de ce type de pouvoir se poser les
bonnes questions et je pense qu'on est
savez ces petites questions là comme et
sous le tapis quand on est en bas âge
mais si c'est l'âge de la pause après je
vais déprimé et non parce que la loi la
question et les grandes comme ça c'est
pas bien droit mais après à cette
question là qui a pris à celle là puis
après celle là non seulement je vais
tendre et lucide et
non il faut mettre les mains dans le
cambouis faut pas la mettre son tapis
cette question quand tu dors mal tu veux
te bernard des multiples ci a loué le
voir qu'en donnant un
nom c'est petite question voulez vous
vraiment mettre la tête de denrées dans
vos pays jusqu'au bout pas parce que si
c'est là que nous faisons et il faut pas
avoir peur de souffrir par rapport à son
faux pas à parcourir et seconde finale
en se posant toutes ses fils toutes ces
questions en fait
en tire le fil de toutes ces questions
entre renforcer nos solutions quelque
part et si on ne peut pas ces questions
nous poursuivrons toujours en vain
jusqu'à demain donc se poser les bonnes
questions et puis après les conditions
de ce silence éloquent cette peine
extérieur par son environnement avoir un
environnement positif d'une maison calme
d'abn s'entourer des bonnes personnes
elle serait authentique par rapport à
celle livrée par rapport à soi pardon
pouvait être un pleinement conscients de
notre vie est vrai dans sa façon par les
autres être authentique et
est authentique ou si avec soin mais
pascal environnement extérieur qu'est-ce
que tu fumes s'y attarde travail
surpoids approfondir la connaissance de
toi pour être en paix à l'intérieur et
pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir un peu à la manière d'un
sismographe pouvoir
ressentir le moindre changement qui se
passe dans le corps moi c'est ce que je
peux te dire tu tacchella pure en veille
sur mon corps j'ai besoin de simples
pouvoir avancer
une fois qu'on a tous à vous parlais
tout à l'heure de mindset de cette
phrase qui est essentielle et puis
carrière faut agir il faut agir tous les
jours
mon prof de yoga et des années ils
disaient tous qu'ils couchent pas dans
le coup avec potentiellement sujet à
bagdad
c'est unique
oui je sais que quand je me suis remis
et en métal je suis un petit parallèle
tout de suite avec elizabeth huart aux
tunnels fermière
spécialistes
[Musique]
du deuil du processus de deuil le
processus de deuil ya le choc il ya des
nids il ya la colère la marchandage et
la dépression et puis en dernier il ya
l'acceptation est en fait dans mon cas
dans le cadre manhattan djicoroni
chroniques dégénératives
jamais soutient pas tellement
d'acceptation possible parce qu'en fait
la malade j'ai voulu tout en hauteur il
faut tout ancien adapté à une nouvelle
situation tout en accepter une nouvelle
situation donc en fait je suis tout le
temps entre acceptation et marc chenal
qui m'incite à pousser des actionnaires
tout en souhaitant la dépression parce
que je suis déprimé je pense pas que
j'ai beaucoup sortir tout appli est un
donc ça va c'est vraiment un problème
dans le monde dans ce curieux au
quotidien un problème dont me suis fait
que je suis là aujourd'hui on nous parle
d'action et est en fait c'est pas la
victoire qui compte aujourd'hui je suis
pas guéri c'est pas la victoire qui
compte c'est de continuer à agir citant
cioni léger siècle et continue à agir
juste se battre tous temps tous les
jours
et cette action ben c'est du sport donc
c'est la course à pied c'est du vo c'est
du travail c'est du yoga c'est de
l'alpinisme c'est de la randonnée s'est
inclinée que je fais tous les jours pour
le désert c'est travailler sur leur
alimentation travailler sur sa qualité
du sommeil travail et surtout t-solar
réfléchir à toi réfléchira à jimmy à
l'intérieur des écouteurs pour anticiper
l'avenir
et puis pour avoir envie de
continuer à cultiver et c'est ça le
verbe d'action japonais cultivés la joie
et l'amour parce que sa sculpture dans
les airs venus les petites fleurs bord
du sentier
bien regarder sa copine dans les yeux et
dudit reconnaît et puis partage de dire
entourage de problème du tiercé pendant
dix ans à venir
est-ce que sa solution d'une autre chose
concède en fait j'aime bien aussi qu
elle lâché prise c'est soit jetée
choisir peut pas choisir
et là je peux j'y pense oui
et puis eur puis à la prépa et issam lui
dit simplement dit ça que l'on fait pour
savoir lâcher prise c'est choisir de pas
choisi et d en perdre ta toutes les
infos et tu sauras jamais la vérité tu
vas y passer des heures en jouant des
années à savoir à connaître la vérité tu
s'inscrivent au pointage quand fait
pouvoir chercher à le faire
des fois y'a rien y'a rien comprenez ya
juste eu
des fois par jour
et donc
de chansons message en fait vous l'avez
compris il est tourné vers l'action il
ya une deuxième partie d'un message
qu'ils ressentent le sens qu'on donne
tout ce qu'on fait aux cliniciens 2010
ans toujours en revenir au sens plus
c'est dur qui ont nourri un sens
comme dans ses racines qu'il faut
avancer et âme
le sens c'est aussi le rêve c'est aussi
le rêve
d'avoir moins qu'au début l'objectif
cela-dit simplement c'est de vivre est
dit pleinement
et puis au final
pas tous des passes qui jeu tout ce que
je viens de vous dire cette résilience
maintenant perdu alors tout à l'heure
vous
dit pas toute la vérité c'est qu'en fait
à bas depuis dix ans où j'ai pris cinq
fois le mans accompagne avec 5 aux
besoins de capacité respiratoire
j'ai mis quatre heures 2015
puis dix ans j'ai couru tout un tas de
trail du court central c'est quasi la
verticale d'une chamonix le chiffre de
sertic adjani par la verticale tour
eiffel et puis j'ai fait tout a pas de
sonner dans les alpes dans les pierriers
3 mm quatre duels d'abord
le grand milieu d'un euro par action
et puis trois tentatives ont blanchi au
sommet du mont blanc je suis en juin 18
après trois tentatives et celui dont je
vous raconte tout à l'heure c'était
depuis mont blanc c'est un peu plus aux
petits pieds pour moi j'ai répondu et
l'opportunité d'une année
et je vais aller faire soulever encore
plus beau et aujourd'hui nous sommes et
en fait je vous disais tout à l'heure
j'ai beaucoup de chance pour moi de
juillet je vérifie s'il avoue
médicaments qui m'a fait gagner 30 % 25
81 64 est l espérance ngaba
extraordinaire que je n'ai plus rien du
tout dans les pouilles c'est un truc de
dingue jbouri sous pli depuis juillet du
coup j'ai gagné beaucoup de temps et
d'énergie pour réfléchir à ce que c'est
que la vie ça sert parce que finalement
vous avez des entretiens et aujourd'hui
parce que j'ai du temps toutefois il
faut lui tombe à nos enfants
sénart c'est pas facile
j'ai bien peur que ça mais je me dis je
vais quand même et puis
médicament aujourd'hui la résilience et
38 dans le fait que j'ai envie de
profiter du temps qu'il est un parti qui
est offert la grâce à ce nouveau
traitement pour rebondir encore le plus
possible continuer à faire peut-être
devenir peuvent obtenir la plus tard
gagner en souplesse continue à bouger
continuer à pourrir
et
la maladie donc final ces opportunités
extraordinaires
et tout le problème
toute difficulté c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire pour faire plein de
choses pour rencontrer des gens
extraordinaires
et pour au final accomplir tous les
défis j'ai réalisé que je donne aussi du
sens à ce que je suis donc
action à son action il faut bouger c'est
maintenant que ça se passe on a parlé
d'environnement n'a pas les pleins de
choses pour moi ou devait augmenter la
capacité de résilience c'est ça aussi
c'est la permaculture sets zéro déchet
c'est un consommé moins de plastique
consommer et tic durables acheter du
matos solide et à il travaillait aussi
pour des entreprises qui respectent
l'environnement et qui convient dans ce
sens voilà
et au final
d'avoir incité au moins de janvier
5895 mètres d'altitude
ça y est on est aux portes du parc de
kilimandjaro
historique
à la betty km 41 ans 5h10
[Musique]
même pas
quand 0
[Musique]
globalement
améliorée
qui ne flanche pas c'est mon
[Musique]
territoire hakuna matata
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais le gars qui arrive là
et il est en train de gravir le
kilimandjaro
après avoir fait le mont blanc plusieurs
fois il arrive il est là
c'est bon
vous foulez web
[Musique]
ça c'est fait
aïe
la machine
[Applaudissements]
ce changer ces changements
[Musique]
se changer à l'intérieur c'est changer
l'eau qui avait comme ca proviendra à
seul à seul
[Applaudissements]